you
[Music]
so it's an honor to have Tom Dietrich
with us today I've known I think I
remember the first moment I think I ran
it at the time I was passing a seminar
room and looked in and then walked in at
Stanford in Robert Jack's Hall and there
was some sort of a great interesting
debate going on on some machine learning
topic I think what the folks were there
isn't and so it's a just a memory that
I've had of the past I just remember the
first glimmer of the energy of Tom
Dietrich I've come to know and love his
work over the years Tom mentioned during
our fireside chat the video he did last
night together that was we're talking a
little bit about interests and this idea
of that I think we share one thing we
both have what we called it
research attention deficit disorder we
we we get very curious and excited about
many topics and it's amazing to me how
deep Tom goes on each of them that he he
attacks over the years Tom did his
undergraduate work at Oberlin and then
did his master's at UIUC I think you
mentioned you were following the time
the end of the line of where you find
the the best computer sticking phones
into these 300 baud sockets and so on in
those days and and and then did his
graduate work at Stanford University
following I guess he ran into Bruce
Buchanan after hanging out with Makowski
at UIUC got him into the machine
learning world and has worked on in many
different areas
I think following all the recent trends
and some leading some of them remember
you and I were at the first uii
conference in 1985 together and I
remember you wearing a pair of shorts
and asking hard questions in front of
the room back in those days I don't
forget anything
Tom so he's in these interesting
interactions we've had over the years
going to the published graphical models
there phase has always been touching on
applications
that then quite a lot of work during the
Kahlo project on desktop events and
understand trying to infer the
intentions of goals of users from
desktop streams of evidence more
recently has been has been looking like
like several of us here at the the
challenge of AI in the open world issues
about robustness and understandability
of these algorithms he was a leader in
this whole area that's now called
computational sustainability working
with Carla gomes at cornell at defining
this area and somehow convincing the
National Science Foundation to fund it
deeply looking at applications of
optimization and other areas of machine
intelligence to hard challenges with
environment and speciation and resource
management of Planetary Resources sort
of resonating with our AI for Earth Day
effort here now at Microsoft today he'll
be talking about a piece of this
interesting area I'm robustness I think
it's an important aspect anomaly
detection algorithms explanations and
applications Tom thanks very much for
being with us thank you is this way yeah
yes oh can you hear me yes okay so of
course everything that I'm talking about
today was done by someone else so so
this is a collaboration with two felt
two of my fellow faculty in computer
science alan fern and wayne keen wang
when keen is currently rotating at NSF
as a program manager so but he'll be
back in the fall and then two faculty
from Statistics Sharma 2 Bhattacharya
and Debashish mundial and at least one
of them did their thesis at UWA but I
don't remember which one and then
several graduate students and as their
their contributions come up I'll be
pointing those out in the talk so I have
a sort of long agenda here this is
more than I would usually try to cover
in one talk but some of them are fairly
straightforward so what I want to do is
start by defining this question of
anomaly detection what do we mean by
that because that that's not a terribly
well-defined term and then I'll report
briefly review a big benchmarking effort
we did in the mostly in the knowledge
discovery in database community there
there have been many many algorithms
published in the anomaly detection area
I think largely because they have many
business problems in fraud detection and
management and this is a big tool there
and but a lot of those are just
publishing an algorithm a mechanism
without any kind of a theoretical
foundation and so we wanted to
understand them and then we we've done a
bit of work on on a probably proximately
correct type of machine learning theory
for what we call rare pattern anomaly
detection then then I'll talk about
scenarios like fraud detection where you
you you have you have a ranked list of
anomalous transactions or users or
whatever and now there's an you have an
analyst in the loop and so you want to
show the analyst say that you're number
one candidate and and explain to them
why you think it's anomalous obviously
it's not sufficient to dump 180 element
vector on them and say we think this is
an anomalous user but we want so so I'll
talk about some very simple feature
based explanations and then if we've got
the analyst in the loop we can also get
feedback from them and use that to
re-rank our candidates as we're
presenting them and that turns out at
least in our in our benchmarking to be
really powerful and then I'll wrap up
with two applications one which is a big
sort of sustainability application
involving deploying 20,000 sensor
weather stations in sub-saharan Africa
and then trying to automatically detect
when stations break and sensors break
and so on and the other is a sort of
open world AI problem which is the
problem of open category classification
in say multi-class classification so
defining anomalies so we're going to
assume that our data are just feature
vectors in d dimensional real space and
that we have a data set that is a
mixture of what we'll call the nominal
points so that we don't call them the
normal points and we'll cut and the
others will call the anomalies and and
our assumption is that the anomalies are
generated by a different generative
process than the nominal points but but
typically our data will be unlabeled
we'll talk about that I guess on the
next slide which is they're really three
settings so so in some cases people have
tried to formulate this as a supervised
learning problem so we we get some
labeled data but in most most of these
sort of anomaly detection applications
they're the anomalies are quite rare
from fortunately you know fifty percent
of our users are not trying to defraud
us although maybe it seems like that at
times but and so we would have severe
class imbalance if we approach things
from that perspective another
possibility is that we are training on
clean data that has no anomalies in it
but but then maybe at test time we're
going to get contaminated data and we
need to identify those contaminants and
that's that what happens in the open
category case and then in other
situations where our training data is
contaminated with some kinds of
anomalies and we want to figure out
which points those might be so that so
we'll be looking at those so I think a
very important consideration here is
this assumption I call the W dad
assumption the assumption that the
anomalies are drawn from a well-defined
probability distribution so if just to
back up if you're formulating things in
a supervised learning way you are
essentially assuming my anomalies are
coming from some well-defined
distribution right and I can learn about
that but but if we're in an adversarial
setting like in the fraud or
cybersecurity kinds of settings then
that really is not a valid assumption to
make right in fact our adversaries are
constantly trying to defeat whatever
distributional assumptions we've made
another case in the weather network case
it it seems like it's adversarial in the
sense that there it's sort of the number
of ways something can be anomalous is
sort of an unbounded set and I guess
technically speaking it's still a
well-defined probability distribution
but you don't have nearly enough data to
have sampled the whole thing so you
really can't model it and another case
that's come up I've collaborated a
little bit with kiri Wagstaff at the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory and and they're
the the user is usually a scientist and
they're looking at data coming from some
sensor like she's worked on some
spectrometers that are on on the Mars
Science Observatory and and the the what
the expert wants is is to find the
interesting data points now the first
few interesting data points are actually
oh ways that the instrument fails and
they need to understand those but then
then they start being interested in you
know unusual spectra that might signal
some interesting compounds but then once
they've seen those then they say well
don't show me any more of those I want
to see you know show me real anomalies
and so it's a time changing notion so so
I think yeah we we need to be sensitive
to to when it's appropriate to make this
assumption so there's there I think two
main strategies I think for unsupervised
anomaly detection and it depends a lot
on on this parameter that we call alpha
which is the fraction of the training
points or test points that are that will
be these anomalies if alpha is
reasonably large then we can think about
fitting something like a two component
mixture model and actually trying to
model that anomaly distribution if we're
willing to make this well-defined
distribution assumption and you know
there are various conditions for that to
work alternatively if the if the
proportion of anomalies is very small as
it typically is in in in these fraud
cases then the main strategy is to treat
it as a problem of outlier detection so
we're not going to we're going to try to
model then the distribution of the
nominal points the the ordinary users
and and then treat the outliers as our
candidate anomalies and the viana severe
is that we don't have to make any
deception about the distribution but of
course if if if the anomalies are not
outliers then then we will we will miss
some of them and also if the nominal
distribution itself has very heavy tails
so that it just naturally has a lot of
outliers this won't work either so so as
I mentioned in the in the kdd literature
there there must be 20 or 30 different
algorithms that have been published you
know there's a huge number of papers
there and and a problem with many of
these is that they unlike in a lot of
other parts of machine learning and
computer vision and natural language
processing there are not there's not a
large collection of standard benchmark
data sets that you could do a thorough
evaluation on these algorithms often you
know there's a some sort of a corporate
application with a proprietary data set
that they can't share and then there and
then the most popular benchmark data set
is this computer intrusion data set that
was collected as part of a DARPA project
back in the late 90s and it turns out to
be extremely easy so so we we you know
strongly believe in benchmarking and the
need to have a large and constantly
growing collection of anomaly benchmarks
and so my student Andrew Emmett
conducted a big benchmarking study and
our methodology was to repurpose
existing supervised learning benchmarks
either classification or regression
problems so we chose nineteen data sets
from the UC Irvine deposit repository
that which were all the data sets that
satisfied a set of criteria we had we
wanted real valued features we wanted
enough data we wanted enough dimension
and then we would choose one or more of
the classes to be these anomaly classes
the source of our anomalies and the rest
to be the nominals and this ensures that
that our anomaly points are being
directed you know created by some
process that's different from the data
that's creating the nominals
and then we systematically varied things
like alpha the relative frequency of the
anomalies
the difficulty of the points like how
deeply embedded are they inside a
nominal distribution versus how much are
they outliers we added redundant or
irrelevant features to see how much that
could defeat the algorithms and we also
looked at how clustered the the anomaly
points are right because to a large
extent these anomaly detection
algorithms are all something that some
form of approximate density estimation
right you're essentially trying to model
the probability density of the of the
nominal points and then score points
according to how the the very low
density points are your anomalies now if
the anomalies are all tightly clustered
then they form a little peak of density
they don't look like their low density
anymore and so you'll miss them so we
were we were interested in in that and
we created twenty replicates for each
configuration of these manipulated
values and that gave us about twenty
five thousand different benchmark data
sets so then we compared a set of eight
different algorithms I won't go through
all of them but basically there are
there are some that are doing density
estimation some that are we have called
the quantile based methods like the one
class support vector machine is probably
the best-known of those it tries to find
a boundary around your data that
contains say one minus Delta of your
data for some quantile you choose Delta
there our nearest neighbor type distance
methods and then there are these
projection methods and I want to talk
about these because these two algorithms
turn out to be very attractive for many
reasons so the first algorithm and the
one that actually performed the best on
our benchmarking exercise is something
called the isolation forests and the in
and those of you who know me know I love
decision trees and anything random
forests boosting all these things so I I
had a natural affinity for this
algorithm although I when I first saw
this paper came out I said this is such
a weird idea but the basic ideas were
going to construct a fully completely
random binary tree right our again
recall that our late our data are not
labeled so we just choose one of the
attributes at random and then we choose
a splitting threshold
uniformly random out of the observed
range of the data and then we do that
split the data recursively and we split
this in some sense overfitting radically
and so every data point is in its own
leaf in the tree I mean in in the paper
actually they they have ways of avoiding
happens to do that you can stop the
splitting at some point and the idea and
we'll build an ensemble of these and the
statistic we're interested in is
actually the depth of a point in the
tree at which the depth at which a point
becomes completely isolated like let's
say that that my one one data point X I
is the only data point in this leaf node
here then we would say X I is isolated
at depth three and the intuition here is
in some sense we're just throwing like a
dartboard random separating separators
at the data and how many random
separations do we have to do before a
data point is separated from all the
rest of the data and the intuition is
well if you're an outlier you're it's
gonna take only a few random shots and
we'll get you isolated whereas if you're
deeply embedded in a tight cluster I'm
gonna have to split split split split
forever to get down to two isolating you
and so the anomaly score that we get
well so d bar is going to be the average
isolation depth over the 100 trees say
some ensemble and then one nice thing in
this paper is that they they calculate
the expected isolation depth from from a
little bit of theory and so then they
can normalize this so that it lies in a
zero one scale where anomalies are given
a score as close to one and the nominal
points will typically have scores less
than 0.5 for around 0.5 the other
algorithm I want to talk about yeah yes
mm-hm
favor a particular basis of the features
right if you have a linear transform of
the features you kill at different paces
right this is invariant so like for
example if you have like the point is
not obviously a liar in you know one
basis but like if you
four minutes for example if you don't
like a spear and then like it's fuzzy
around that like I don't know if you can
tell just by looking at just will be a
one basis it's true and so of course
we've also looked at randomly rotating
the data before we top it up it helps a
little bit but the randomness increases
the variance of the isolation depth so
then we have to make me ensemble bigger
so it hasn't been enough of a game to be
worthwhile to us because you know the
memory starts to be a an issue here well
so in nature I don't know in our in our
benchmark data sets and in like our
fraud detection applications the
features are generally meaningful so and
we're not doing this on images or things
like this where we're pixel 25 has no
particular meaning at all right it's so
yeah so I certainly wouldn't use this
out of the box on images that would be
crazy maybe I would use it in the
penultimate layer of a CNN or something
not even convinced that would be a good
idea but certainly squared but usually I
mean just as decision trees basically
are looking at higher order interactions
right as you go deeper you're looking at
these things pretty much follow the data
distribution right we only put splits
where we have data so they do a pretty
good job there was an interesting paper
by nina mishra i think and colleagues at
ICML a couple years ago where they
analyzed a slight variant of this
algorithm and showed that that that the
isolation depth is is related to an LP
norm on the distance between the outlier
and the data so in this case basically
an l1 norm you can sort of imagine how
this would be sort of like an l1
distance so it it has it I mean I think
you know if you look at these these
different anomaly these different
rhythms I think a lot of them are
essentially doing something that's very
similar I mean the nearest neighbor
algorithms are calculating some distance
and the isolation forest is definitely
calculating something like a distance
also and clearly these things are using
a kernel distance and these things are
using something like a Gaussian kernel
in the original space so yeah I mean of
course you could apply PCA to try to you
know rectify the data in some sense the
other method that I want to mint is it I
should say are there any other questions
and yes do any of your data sets
benchmark data sets include behavioral
data so sequential data that was
generated by capturing traces of
someone's behavior like network
intruders behavior no I mean so when we
applied this in this DARPA we were in
this DARPA program called Adams and and
there we were looking at an organization
that had 5,000 employees and we had
actual sort of desktop spyware installed
monitoring software on their desktops
they were working for some organization
in the military-industrial complex
that's all I'm allowed to say but and so
we we had we could go down and really
look at like every email message they
sent and and even the content and all
that stuff but we summarized that at a
daily time step and turn it into sort of
a vector of how many mail emails did
they send how many websites did they
visit how many of this and then the
other thing and then we also did some
normalization to try to deal with both
both asking how unusual was this day
compared to the typical day of this user
and how unusual was this this user on
this day compared to everybody else in
the company on that day because we
otherwise we had these things where some
some new web link would be sent out
through the whole company and everybody
go visit it and nobody had ever visited
that link before and we would get all
excited if we were only looking at one
user so I mean so we had to do some
pretty serious feature engineering to
turn this into something that was caught
you know almost iid
but it but then all these algorithms are
purely for that sort of feature vector
case and and in my weather data were
again having to figure out how we can
engineer the features to take what is
very much a spatial temporal time series
and and turn it into little database
views that are that are approximately
exchangeable so
okay well the the second algorithm I
want to mention it's even simpler is is
called Lodha and-and-and what given a
set of data points what it does is is
create a set of capital m say again say
a hundred sparse random projections so
it randomly chooses a square root of D
where D is the dimension of the data
square root of D of the dimensions and
then and then defines a random
projection onto a one dimension and then
fits a one dimensional density model
I've drawn it as a kernel density
estimate but they actually use a an
adaptive histogram estimator and and and
then what they do is just calculate the
the the average of the minus log density
of a query point so the average surprise
and we can see if we took a data point
like this one right here it would be
have a pretty high probability in this
projection but of course if we got some
other projection then it would be mapped
to a to a low density tale and so this
is a extremely simple idea but also
we're surprisingly well presumably
because there are not super Howard or
interactions in our data so so like
looking at three or four dimensions at a
time works pretty well so then how do we
do our analysis we I point you to the to
the archive papers for for the details
but but we basically chose a couple of
metrics either the area under the ROC
curve which we put through a loggia
transform or the the the log of the lift
which is related to the area under the
precision recall curve and and then and
just tried to set up a linear model to
say it across all of these benchmarks
how could we explain how much of the
variation in the metric could be
explained by the relative frequency of
the anomalies the difficulty of the
points the clustered miss the amount of
irrelevant features what we call the
mother set the original the domain from
from which the original dataset was
drawn and which algorithm we were using
because I
wanted to say well you know a typical
finding in machine learning is that that
the choice of problem is much more
important than which algorithm you use
and we were curious if that was true
here or not and the answer is pretty
much true also so so here are the those
sort of five factors and here is the
change in the in the sort of in the R
squared basically how much variation can
we explain in these two metrics so under
the area to the ROC curve if we take a
model and delete the data set feature
how much do much R squared do we lose or
how much can we assign to the data set
and and that's the most important a
variable for explaining the observed AUC
next is the relative frequency so the if
you have a data set with very where the
anomalies are very rare we can do very
well right because we have very little
contamination as the anomalies get more
common than this these techniques fail
because really only one of them has any
explicit attempt to be robust and use a
robust loss that's this technique called
robust kernel density estimation all the
others are just plunging forward fitting
some kind of a model and so the choice
of algorithm is really only the third
most important factor and really not a
whole lot more important than the others
but with that caveat here are the the
different algorithms that we tested
sorted by you know decreasing change in
the metric compared to a control
baseline and what we see is that
actually the isolation forest was
performing better than the other methods
and then there's sort of like a five way
tie for second place and surprisingly
the one class support vector machine and
support vector data description really
performed the worst on these problems
which is quite a shock because I think
if you asked a random machine learning
person if I had a one class problem and
I needed to fit it what would you use
and they'd all say well gee how about
you know don't choke off has this
algorithm right we're a little puzzled
about this and of course it's possible
that we just didn't tune these proper
although we tried a lot of things but we
wanted to have a fully automated tuning
procedure and so it may be that we
didn't do that well but but there have
been some papers recently in the
literature on auto tuning those and so
we were trying to use the current best
practices my my own hypothesis here is
that that that you know the the metrics
that we're evaluating on are really
related to how well you can rank the
data points whereas these methods really
just set it up as a are you inside or
outside of a particular quantile a
particular level set of the density so
it's not clear that they're really being
trained for the right to do well on
these metrics and so maybe that's why
they don't do as well as some of these
more distance eBay store density based
approaches so we also find in general
that the isolation force is a bit more
robust to irrelevant features and that
it's also a bit more robust to two
clustered anomaly points so that may be
why it has this slight advantage over
the other methods okay well let's move
on now to thinking about whether we
could have some kind of a theory to
explain what's going on because one of
the things we were quite surprised at is
when we look at the learning curves
these these algorithms all learned quite
quickly and of course from you know if
we look at well what existing sample
complexity do we theory do we have four
for this kind of one class or density
estimation it's often quite a
discouraging right so if you look at at
at full density estimation you need you
typically need a number of examples
that's exponential in the dimension of
the data and that's not very that
doesn't match our experience and for the
quantile methods there there are
polynomial sample complexity results so
so and our observations or maybe more
consistent with something polynomial
time so so my colleague Alan fern came
up with this theory we call rare pattern
anomaly detection and it works as
follows so we imagine we're going to
define this is very
you know valiant style packed learning
kind of thing we're going to define a
space of patterns or regions so so we'll
define a pattern as a boolean function
that takes a point in d dimensional
space
and maps at either 0 or 1 so it might be
a half plane or an axis parallel hyper
rectangle some kind of region and and
we'll let capital H be the the set of
all the patterns in our pattern space
and then the idea is to define a notion
of a rare pattern and a common pattern
and to do this we we need to do a little
bit of being careful about measures so
we're going to assume some baseline
measure so if if we're in a say a hyper
box in d dimensional space we might use
just the lebesgue measure the uniform
measure over that but if we're in
unbounded real space we need to use
something like a standard multivariate
Gaussian as our baseline measure and and
we'll let em U of H be the measure of
that pattern pattern H and then let's
let P be the probability density of the
nominal data points and it's defined
over Rd also and will appear of H be the
probability assigned to pattern H and so
we'll say a pattern H is Tao rare if the
sort of normalized probability density
is less than or equal to some threshold
tau and otherwise we'll say that pattern
is Tao common and then our definition of
what we want as we're going to say a
data point now a query point is Tao rare
if there exists at our rare pattern that
that data point belongs to right so that
data point belongs in in pattern H and H
is Tao rare so it means there's some way
of looking at the data there's some bin
in the data that this day that this
query point X belongs to that is very
unusual under the under the nominal
distribution and so then our goal an
ideal anomaly detection algorithm would
output all of the Tao rare query points
in in a test set and not output any of
the Tao common points that way
the idea so I guess what's what's say
interesting about this model is that
instead of trying to estimate the entire
density or even trying to estimate a
level set of the density we're just
choosing some set of regions in the
space and just trying to figure out what
they're roughly what their probability
density is or their the probability of
those so and I think that this is why if
we don't have too many of those regions
then we can get uniformly good estimates
over most of them from a relatively
small sample so we define an algorithm
to be probably approximately correct
Arpad if for any probability density p
and any threshold tau it draws a
polynomial size sample and then with
probability 1 minus epsilon it detects
all the tau rare points and rejects does
not output any tau plus epsilon common
points so we have to introduce this sort
of elbowroom parameter allow the
algorithm to make some mistakes so it's
allowed if a point is is between tau
plus epsilon rare and tau rare then the
algorithm can do anything it wants there
and and so what we end up with is as an
algorithm such as the following if we
can draw a polynomial size sample and
we'll talk about this what this is in a
moment and then we just estimate P hat
is the fraction of the sample that
belongs to each of our patterns and and
then we can calculate the normalized
rareness and then we just say a query
point is declared to be an anomaly if
one of these tile rare patterns is made
true by that query point so so we can
prove a sample complexity result that
says that the number of samples we need
is on the order of 1 over epsilon
squared the log of the number of
patterns plus log of 1 over Delta so
very kind of typical PAC result it's a
little unfortunate that this is epsilon
squared here so that's going to mean you
know if if we want Upsilon to be 0.01
then we're going to
you need what 10,000 this will be a big
number a big constant but and then we
can get a vc-dimension version of this
where the v c-dimension plugs in here
times log of 1 or epsilon squared so
there are lots of different you know
practical algorithms you can you can
design with this procedure so you know
half-spaces and access pair access
aligned hyper rectangles and in our
paper we worked out the VC dimension of
all of these and in particular we
designed a version of the isolation for
us that that exactly matches this theory
and to do that we you know the pattern
space has to be chosen a priori for the
in this theory it can't be adaptive to
the data so to deal with that we use the
usual trick there say taking our
training data and dividing it in half
and using half the data to grow an
isolation tree to some fixed depth a
fixed depth K and then using the second
half of the data that fixes our pattern
space and then the second half of the
data we can estimate the probability of
all of these bins and so here are some
examples on some datasets where the
these different the plot on the left is
for the isolation for us the actual
isolation forest algorithm grown to a
fixed depth K and this is our
theoretical version of it also at depth
K the vertical axis is the area under
the ROC curve and I apologize that the
axes are different in the two plots and
then these different lines are for
different depths of tree but if we just
look in this case the depth one trees
actually works the best and we see that
that in this case the the pattern min
method actually does a little bit better
than the isolation forests on the air
end of the ROC curve for another data
set particle the isolation forests does
much better because notice this is 0.71
down to 6 6 and this would be 6 6 down
to 5 2 so all of these curves basically
are below all of these so the isolation
force was much better and then here's
the data set shuttle where where the
Arpad the theoretically inspired
algorithm is actually doing quite a bit
better than isolation forest and
this time I did get the axes aligned so
so so I think qualitatively well the
shapes the curves aren't always the same
but but but yeah there's all there's
sometimes some funny business going on
with very small samples right this is
particularly weird that we do very well
with very small samples and there's an
interesting phenomenon going on here
that we don't fully understand but but
when you have a training sample and it
includes some amount of contamination if
you a standard practice that's done in
the isolation forest is to train on
actually subsets of the data not on the
entire data set and the idea is that
you're kind of thinning out it's a
robusta fication strategy by training on
small on smaller sub samples you you
have the absolute number of
contaminating points is reduced the
fraction is introduced but it seems that
that if you have like a tight cluster of
points you're reducing that local
density of that cluster and I think this
helps the the algorithms do a better job
but we don't have a good theoretical
understanding of this but empirically
even the original authors of the
isolation forest algorithm say that you
should train on a much small on a small
subsets of the data rather than the
entire data set and that this often
helps and you know for those of us in
machine learning it's like what you're
not using all your data but of course
we're building an ensemble so across the
whole ensemble we're using all of our
data and the smaller the subsets the
bigger the ensemble needs to be because
you also have to reduce the variance
that you've introduced by by choosing
these random subsets so so this is a
paradox that we're this kind of thing
where the small sample is actually
performing well I mean it's not observed
all the time but it's observed enough of
the time that we think it's a real
phenomenon and and we're trying to find
a nice theoretical understanding of it
okay so the conclusions from this is
that we feel that this rare pattern
anomaly detection Theory captures a lot
of the behavior of the isolation forests
or of
in because these methods are doing
solving a simpler problem than full
density estimation or even estimating
level sets of the density and so I guess
maybe I should pause and say are there
any any questions about that yes well I
would guess on very high dimensional
data you need to use a very large
ensemble of trees right you would need
you so let's see what's the right way to
talk about this I mean if you if your if
your space of rare patterns is in some
sense I think you you want to if you if
you have a distribution of the data you
want to have these rare patterns kind of
surrounding the data right and and
obviously one intuition is that in high
dimensional space though you're going to
need a lot of those patterns surrounding
the the cloud of data and so the number
of patterns you might need to really
tile the the entire region might might
grow exponentially and so you know our
result says well it the sample size is
polynomial and the number of patterns
but the number of patterns that you need
might be exponential so that's a that's
a good question we have not tried this
on a bag of words thing for example as a
yeah now one might hope you know what so
the you know I'll do the standard
machine learn anything and say oh but
the data really lives in a low
dimensional manifold and so all we have
to do is identify that manifold then
well but we know that tree type
algorithms will in some sense follow
that manifold and so we would maybe
we'll still do okay I'm waving my hands
yeah yes so it's use exterior is knowing
the pattern space right but then if
you're dealing with anomaly detection I
mean many say you know successful
intrusions happen exactly because there
is
some sort of behavioral pattern that you
didn't take into account and so the
adversary was able to exploit it so does
this is there a way to extend I'll fix
this theory to maybe at least give you
some indication that there is something
in the data for which you don't maybe
have a pattern or you didn't miss the
pattern but that it may be an anomaly
well if we think about what for instance
the isolation forest does it actually
partitions the entire input space into
patterns so there is always a pattern
for every possible observation many of
those patterns will be essentially empty
in fact I sort of skipped over a little
detail of the isolation for us but when
you do a split at a node and you split
the data there you now have you keep
track of there's little empty spaces
between the observed range of the data
in the children and the observed range
in the parent and and they're actually a
query point can fall into that empty
space in in in between the observed
ranges in articulate here about this but
but if I if I have a set a lot of data
points along a line and I choose an
arbitrary split right there's going to
be some space between adjacent in
instances and that empty space affected
with the algorithm allocates a two
additional patterns for that empty space
because if a query point comes down it's
considered to be isolated if it falls
into this space it was inside the range
of the parent and outside the range of
the child and and that turns out to be
really important you know if you don't
do this right then the performance of
the algorithm suffers quite a lot so I
guess my first point would be that if we
use the some of the data to build the
tree structure and if the tree structure
is really following the structure of the
data then we will have tiled the space
nicely in every leaf node by
construction is going to be very is
going to be rare because it will have at
most one point in it so we're going to
have a lot of reasons that have
essentially zero points or one point in
them and we've also completely tiled the
space so if there is an unusual behavior
it will fall into one of these empty
spaces basically and will be detected
then how do you tell between interesting
anomalous behaviour and uninteresting
animals well yeah because we're only
doing outlier detection here and we have
no knowledge yeah that an outlier we
can't tell the difference between an
outlier that's part of the natural
variation of the distribution and an
outlier that's due to to some unusual
behavior that's caused by something
different like a fraudster or something
yeah in fact of course a fraudster is
going to try to mimic the the nominal
distribution and so you know we might
want to try to use you know some you
know essential behavior things that they
that the fraud fraudulent user is not
able to manipulate to help us detect
their behavior right that but all I'll
say is that in in the competitions
inside this DARPA program we were number
one in several months using these kind
of techniques so maybe that's a tribute
to our future engineering skills or
maybe the red team made it too easy I
don't know but but these methods were
working pretty well and we're competing
against an IBM team that actually has a
product in this space so I don't know it
okay well let me move on now to assuming
that we can find these anomalies how can
we explain them to the user so so our
basic idea is the following we we we
were really troubled by you know what
constitutes a good explanation and how
could we measure that in a in a rigorous
way without doing human subject studies
and so here is the thing that we came up
with we we imagine that the goal of our
of our anomaly detection system is to
persuade the analyst that a candidate
anomaly is a real anomaly and the idea
is we're going to expose one feature at
a time to the analyst and in the worst
case until we've presented all the
different features to the analyst and
then with an appropriate visual
tool until we've either convinced the
analyst that it really is an anomaly or
the analyst says no it isn't and we sort
of view the analyst their job is really
to decide whether to say launched an
internal investigation like a fraud
investigation or not and so so this is
the the kind of model here and so we
call this a sequential feature
explanation and we had a paper at UA I
two years ago on this and so we do very
so so in pictures right
the vertical axis here is the experts or
the analysts assessment of woody of the
probability that the data point is a
nominal not an anomaly given given the
features you've seen so far so we'll say
that notionally it starts out pretty
close to one because is it say you know
1 minus epsilon where epsilon is the
background probability of being an
anomaly and an hour sequential feature
explanation is some permutation of the
features say feature number 3 we think
is the most important so we start
presenting these features to the expert
and if if we're being persuasive the
experts a posterior belief that this is
a normal point starts to drop you know
and hopefully goes to zero and what we
do is to some threshold and and we say
that the the that we called the we
talked about our metric is something we
call the minimum feature prefix MFP
which is the in this case will be four
it took us the first four features in
our ordering we're required to drive the
experts assessment down below say point
whatever that is 0.25 so we so this is
the MFP is our is our metric and across
the whole data set of anomalies will
look at the average of that as being our
performance metric so so if our anomaly
detector is working well then or if we
have a good explanation algorithm it
should it should use short explanations
so this is you know it's sort of the
minimum kind of thing we might have and
obviously it's only appropriate for
problems where the features are meaning
so so so in this case our technique we
relied on another one of our anomaly
detectors which is an ensemble of
Gaussian mixture models so the II GMM
algorithm and we had originally
developed this just as a control so
we're we apply PCA and then in the PCA
space we fit an ensemble of Gaussian
mixture models where we randomly vary
the the number of mixture components and
the starting initialization and and we
discard mixture components that didn't
fit the data very well or you know and
of the ones that survived then we
calculate the the we can get the you
know the we the well our nomally scores
actually the again the average surprised
across those models so it's the product
of the density estimates I guess and and
so then we use a simple greedy algorithm
so we we we we the score of a particular
feature is how much the the the log
likelihood drops when we marginalize out
or I've got this backwards there should
probably a minus sign here it's how much
the surprise decreases when we compare
the marginalize distribution to the
original distribution so right that this
will always have a higher probability
density after we've marginalized that
one feature then the full distribution
did had and and so we do this we first
score each feature and the one that the
led to the biggest change in the density
we say that's the feature with the
biggest impact and then we remove it
from from this set of candidate features
and add it to our answer and just do
that in a greedy fashion and and again
we used a bunch of our of our data sets
we only use seven of the domains the UCI
domains instead of 19 in this study and
instead of using real human analysts we
trained regular eyes random forests on
the supervised version of the data so
they can see all of the data
and and then then we use and the
question was we would convince them if
they you know if they saw all the first
you know four features is their
predicted probability that it belongs to
the anomaly class or to the nominal
class as it dropped below some threshold
and so we compared it against a random
ordering of the features and against an
Oracle that actually knows the labels of
the data right and and what we saw was
that we always did better than random so
and sometimes we do almost as well as
the Oracle so so this is random ordering
this is the Oracle in blue and this is
our as our greedy algorithm and you know
sometimes we don't do as well I guess
one thing that's kind of interesting is
that for most of these irvine type
domains on average the oracle only needs
to show the analyst one or at most two
features to give an explanation so that
that's convincing so that's kind of
interesting and this gives us a kind of
metric of how hard a dataset is so if we
look at the KD 1999 dataset for instance
it's always the case that you need only
one feature even even our even our
algorithm only needs to use one feature
to to explain an anomaly whereas if we
look at our in this atoms insider threat
database you need about seven on average
so it's a much more challenging problem
well if we're going to be talking to an
analyst and and getting and convincing
them we can also get feedback from an
analyst so we wanted to also then look
at could we take the feedback from the
analyst and feed it back into our
anomaly detection process to re-rank the
the candidates that we have and so we
had a paper at ICD M a year and a half
ago showing that that this this could be
a potentially big win so what we do is
we require one parameter which is a
quantile in it basically corresponds to
how many cases can an analyst look look
at in in in the given like in a day
or a month whatever the whatever the
time period is that were analyzing and
so the idea is that you know the analyst
can look at say sixty cases in a month
we want to optimize the 60 cases we
present so so we start by presenting to
the analysts the most the
highest-scoring anomaly we have and then
the analyst says yes that's a that's a
case and I'm going to open investigation
or no it isn't and then we feed back
that and what we try to do is to learn
to reweighed in this case we're working
with the lota anomaly detector which
remember creates a bunch of random
projections one-dimensional random
projections so we learned to reweighed
those production projections to try to
rank all the known anomalies above
quantile tau and all the known nominals
below quantile tau and to do this we
used a modification of a method from
Steven Boyd and and famous colleagues
called accuracy at the top that was
published at nips several years ago now
and so so we're Arirang 'king based on
feedback from the expert and we call
this active anomaly detection and
actually I don't think I really I guess
the only interesting thing is that you
know if the anomalies are fairly rare
then we will have a significant false
alarm rate so it could very well be that
the first three or four five ten cases
we showed that the analysts aren't none
of them are are actual fraud cases what
can we do well one of the advantages of
this of having this threshold tau is
that even with no positive examples we
still learn to push down all of those
non anomalies below this threshold tau
and so this seems to help us learn even
even without any positives but we had to
make some minor modifications so we
compared it against a baseline where we
do no learning we just take our initial
anomaly scores and present them in that
order we looked at randomly ordering
them and then this is our method and
then there are two other methods in the
literature one called ai2 which I don't
think has ever been published except as
a csail tech report and so it's probably
a class project or something although it
works quite well in some cases and
there's something called SSA D which was
in a G R paper and their method from
Granite's at all is is called margin
marginalize and cluster I think we
thought we had an idea for improving it
using our accuracy at the top method but
as you'll see it was not an improvement
but just for completeness and so what
we're going to plot in these plots is
along the horizontal axis is how many
cases have we presented to the to the
analyst and the vertical axis is how
many of them turned out to be true
anomalies and again all this is done but
the simulated analyst and so on but and
so we can see that our baseline method
is this blue curve and so if we have a
budget of 60 cases we can look at we
find about I don't know a 25 or 26 or
something whereas if we can incorporate
our feedback we get you know 45 so huge
advantage from having the analyst and
loop however this is the KD 1999 data
set which is extremely easy so let's
move on to some other ones so this is a
abalone data set and here well early on
we get some benefit of our method over
our baseline right this is our this is
our baby no feedback is the blue curve
and ours is the red curve and then this
is this SSA D method which is doing just
about as well as ours so but if we say
well suppose we only had time to look at
20 cases then we'd still be seeing you
know more than a factor of 2 improvement
eventually obviously if you got far
enough on this there would be no benefit
because eventually we'll have shown
everything to the analyst so here's
another one for thyroid in this case
again compared to our baseline
we're doing pretty well in this case
this ai2 method is doing up almost as
well as we are but again the benefit is
potentially almost a factor 2 in terms
of the number of anomalies we can detect
and in a manner graffia
similar story so so in general for all
these we're seeing that incorporating
the annals feedback can be really
powerful at least for this lota
algorithm but now let me speculate about
why this might
overly optimistic we have to remember
that these data sets that we've
constructed here are constructor from
the supervised learning data sets and
and what's going on when we re wait
these different projections we're
essentially re-weighting the original
features and putting more weight on some
than on others and so it could be that
because our anomalies are coming from
classes in a classification problem that
were presumably determined to be classes
because they were believed to be
separable using the features right it
may be that we're essentially in a sort
of sneaky way of learning a classifier
and taking advantage of that
so it's not clear you know in a real
fraud detection case would we get these
same sort of factor of two improvements
however we have a paper under review
right now i KD d where we're doing
rewedding for isolation forests using a
sort of online learning strategy and we
have applied this to this advanced
persistent threat cyber security case
which is not a supervised learning case
and we're still seeing a substantial not
a factor two but a substantial benefit
from from integrating the feedback yes
they will they will so you have your
classes right did you put some level
noise it's gonna start mixing the
classes there won't be Superboy oh you
mean when we constructed the that's
interesting yeah we we should
interesting we should maybe look at that
that would be a good test at least for
this particularly yeah right and and I
guess another thing is we could create
benchmarks where our our nominal points
come from say just one class and the
anomalies are from the mixer of all the
other classes so hmm we might think that
or maybe maybe we should use lots of
each classes so that there's probably
not a simple sum decision boundary that
separates the nominals from the
anomalies because there'll be very very
multimodal distributions on both sides
yeah so the feedback
very example driven right on the analyst
judging thing right it seems like you
could also order it to be feature driven
or going back to your pattern turn
amount terminology patterns right so
like in fraud cases people are often
interested in the patterns like Oh a
small gas station purchase followed by a
big purchase is a pattern right and then
instead the anomalies are evidence that
this pattern exists right have you
thought about trying to order in other
ways where people might be able to give
a more sample efficient feedback over an
entire future as to whether or not I
believe something anomalous is happening
here we have not we did try back in the
to do some sort of model-based work back
in the insider threat data set where we
we had some theories of insider threats
and we designed features specifically to
look for those threats like someone
copying a large number of files onto a
thumb drive but but but this is that
your you have in mind maybe more more of
a knowledge discovery setting where the
the analyst looks at at our anomalies
and says oh maybe if can you do like as
we've been discussing today maybe some
cluster analysis of these anomalies the
way you you guys are clustering mistakes
and say oh I see sort of a pattern in
these and this looks completely bogus to
me this is looks like just some side
effect of some instrument so I don't
want to see any more of these cases like
this for instance or or this looks
interesting to me yeah so everything
that looks like this let me let me label
that whole cluster yeah are you select
examples if you flip them based on asset
based criterion right if you want to
type if you want to exclude a whole
feature if you just randomly select
examples chances are you want to exclude
that feature whereas if you start
selecting
yes yeah we did look at whether this
sort of select the most the biggest
anomaly is the right thing to do and and
when King you may or may not know but
when he was a graduate student was
working on rare rare category discovery
and and there you do have some diversity
tricks and so and of course yeah so we
could think of this as also could we
elicit from the expert again consistent
with some of the things I've been
hearing about here not only is that
anomaly but but I'm gonna call that a
you know a fool anomaly because this
corresponds to a kind of use case I know
this is the check that the credit card
is working before you use it
pattern yeah and we know we haven't
thought about that but it's a great idea
obviously yes can you say what about
diversity because diversity will
definitely change the thickest e of
query versus anomaly and so it's right
you're a quick trick that can completely
change your metric or is that much from
no we would have to we would really have
to also have something in our metric
that rewards diversity like well as you
say if we if we could essentially
present a group of proposed anomalies
and say we think these points are all
anomalous for the same reason are we
right and get feedback on the whole
group at once then that could be that
would be great and then we would the
next square we would use obviously a
different group but we might have to
balance them I know in in real
situations I remember years ago I
visited Bell Labs and Darrow pressure
bond was working on pay phone fraud for
the well wasn't even eighteen t at the
time and and and they not they had
something kind you know some statistical
model they were looking for weird
behavior but they also rank them by how
valuable they were right in terms of the
financial impact of those those frauds
so that was a yeah okay well I'm gonna
move along because we're really behind
so let's talk about these two
applications so the first one is data
cleaning and weather network so
I'm part of a group that's working on
something called the trans Africa
hydro-meteorological Observatory and
it's founded by two folks one is a
colleague of mine John sulker who's a
hydrologist and the other is a guy named
Nick vandergiesen who's at the Technical
University Delft and also a hydrologist
and they were at some World
Meteorological Organization meeting at
which this plot was put up showing where
are their weather stations around the
world that reliably report data to the
World Meteorological Organization and
those purple blue dots are the ones that
are the the good weather stations and we
can see that in most of Latin America
and and Africa the the weather
infrastructure is just very poor and so
they they they you know in the context
of agriculture in in in Africa most
agriculture is rain fed there's not a
lot of irrigation and so and they noted
that when you have very poor sensing
then you can't buy crop insurance
because the insurance companies don't
know what risk they would take they
don't know how to price the insurance
and so that leads the farmers to plant
their plants very far apart so that each
plant under the worst case precipitation
conditions will still get enough water
to do well and there have been field
trials showing that if you do offer crop
insurance then the farmers plant much
more aggressively plant their plants
much closer together and and get a much
higher agricultural productivity as a
result so this is one of these examples
of you know if we could provide better
data this could lead to a you know crop
insurance industry which include it
could in turn lead to higher
agricultural productivity so you know
John sulfur is not a modest man he wants
to have Africa leapfrog over the whole
rest of the world and become the best
sensed continent and of course the price
of sensors is dropping rapidly and we
can now build weather stations that are
very cheap and so we're trying to deploy
20,000 substations across Africa and
then create various data products and I
like to say well you know weather
stations are really cool
but for some reason people want to put
them out in the weather and expose them
to the rain and all kinds of problems
then they break and so you know this is
a kind of Internet of Things project and
and I like to say the Internet of Things
is going to be the Internet of broken
things and so how can we automatically
detect which stations have failed which
sensors have failed and and so we might
approach this as a sort of medical
diagnosis problem if we could say well
you know these sensors tend to get one
of five different diseases can we learn
to recognize the symptoms but this is
one of those cases where we feel like
there's it seems to be an unbounded
number of ways these weather systems can
fail so where there are known symptoms
we can write rules for them or or build
probabilistic models but we want to use
anomaly detection to detect new kinds of
failures and so I think in the interest
of time I won't go through all the
technical stuff here but I'll just say
that we are combining anomaly detection
scores in a dynamic Bayesian network
where we reason about the state of each
sensors and then we're doing a form of
map inference to try to say given the
observations that we made turned into
anomaly scores we try to not just flag
the data with anomaly flags but actually
do some root-cause analysis and say the
reason we that you got this you know
2,000 alarms is due to one particular
thermometer failing for some time
interval so I guess I should say I sort
of the maybe the most interesting or
weirdest move here is you know a typical
problem you have when you try to model
do diagnosis on this as you want to
model the sensor readings as a function
of the the state of the of the sensors
but these sensor distributions can be
very messy and so we replace the actual
distribution of sensor readings by the
anomaly score assigned to the those
sensor readings and this has the nice
virtue of normalizing everything to be
in zero one and having a more
predictable
tribution at least that's our hypothesis
but we don't have definitive results to
prove this and so I'll say we're
currently working a lot on comparing
sensor readings at multiple stations so
then the other problem which is more
related to open world is open category
classification so given that I have
training data for say K classes that
I've collected and I train a multi class
classifier for them but then my test
data may contain queries corresponding
to new classes how can I detect them
those new new those we call them alien
queries the queries that belong to new
kinds of objects and so our approach is
given our training data we train both
our multi class classifier but also an
anomaly detector and so then when an
input query comes in we look at the
anomaly score and if it's greater than
some threshold then we reject that point
and say we think this might belong to a
new category so we're not going to
classify it but otherwise we feed
through our classifier and make our
prediction and so this was for me was
motivated by another ecological problem
which was for about a decade I was
working with some folks at the EPA and
on campus at freshwater stream health
monitoring so the EPA every year in the
United States does their serve
randomized sampling of fresh water
streams and what they do is I use a kick
net which is what these guys are doing
here to collect insect larvae that live
on the the substrate of the streams and
then they bring those specimens into the
lab and currently they manually identify
them to genus or species but this is
very time consuming and so we thought
well we'll build a sort of robotic
device that went can singulate the
specimens as they say and then
photograph them and then we'll use you
know computer vision to tell them apart
and we did this back in you know in the
mid 2000s when everything was bag of
sift and support vector machines as the
classification technology but we got up
into the low 90% correct over well
ultimately 54 categories so we were all
excited about that and then we started
to look at actually deployment and we
realized well although
our collaborators had collected
specimens we had these beautiful
training data for all the specimens the
test samples are going to contain other
stuff there there's more than it turns
out more than 29 species or more than 54
species out there like it's estimated
there some like 1,200 species of
freshwater macro invertebrates as they
call them so this led us to to think
about well how could we deal with this
problem and of course more recently in
computer vision this has become a
popular problem so the so the we were
and so there are several techniques that
are out there but as far as we know no
one has looked at the question whether
we can provide any kind of theoretical
guarantees so we were looking at a set
up now where we have two training sets
one training set is of our clean
training data you know our our
collaborators went out and collected all
these training data for us it's all
nicely labeled and we know there are no
contaminating samples in these but in
addition we're going to require that we
have a unlabeled collection of samples
that are representative of our test
queries and so here we are making the
well-defined anomaly distribution
assumption that our anomaly that we can
get a sample from the distribution of
anomalies in fact even talk about what
it would mean to have a PAC guarantee on
detecting say you know 99% of all the
aliens right there I'm assuming that
that's a sensible statement that there
is such a distribution and so we're
going to assume that the this that this
contaminated sample which we'll call SM
for mixture is a mixture where again the
proportion of the aliens is alpha and so
this density is a mixture of one minus
alpha times the clean distribution p
naught times alpha times this anomaly
distribution now what we want to find is
if let's suppose this is the CDF of the
anomaly scores of the anomaly points and
so we're really interested in say we
wanted to check 95% of the aliens or
anomalies then we want to know this
quantile right the anomaly score that
such that 95% of the probability mass is
greater than that
so we'd like to estimate this Tao at
0.05 or 0.01 or whatever we want so
we'll call this Q quantile 0.05 so we
note that if this is a mixture
distribution since we're in one
dimensional world it's true that for the
cumulative distribution functions also
that the CDF of the anomaly scores for
the mixture distribution is a convex
combination of the nominal distribution
in the anomaly distribution so if you do
little algebra you can say well gee the
anomaly cdf can be calculated we we can
estimate this from data we can estimate
this from data and if someone will just
tell us alpha then or give us maybe a
reasonable upper bound on alpha then we
can use that to estimate this CDF and so
the picture looks something like this
this might be the CDF of the clean data
the black one is the mixture data and
maybe this is our anomaly CDF and so
we're going to set our threshold
somewhere around in here maybe right and
we'll get all the anomalies but we will
have a some number of false alarms too
so of course this all depends on how
good the anomaly detector is and how
well it can distinguish the the aliens
from the from the known classes so when
we look in practice this is an empirical
CDF of the of the clean data this is the
empirical CDF of the mixture data and of
course we're kind of subtracting them
and so unfortunately this thing can go
negative this is the this is the
estimated CDF of the anomalies so it's
pretty sad
but if we have a larger sample it starts
to look reasonable and but it still can
cross this threshold a few times and so
we we look at the largest value of the
anomaly score that crosses this 0.05
line and we set our threshold there and
that's what this pseudocode says and and
then we're able to give us a guarantee a
guarantee that if the number of samples
we in these two data sets is equal to n
then then the required sample size is is
something like this we have a 1 over
epsilon squared term we have something
that's sort of a 1 over alpha
squared term and then we have this which
is a funny thing that comes from the
fact that we're estimating two different
cumulative distribution functions and
there are some concentration results for
CDF's
and so then with probability one minus
Delta the alien detection rate will be
at least 1 minus Q plus Epsilon so once
again we need some elbow room in in this
in the form of some some some epsilon
and so anyway anyway so that's what we
can do and then experimentally I don't I
didn't put the results here but we have
a paper under review for ICML where we
also show experimental results for this
and of course it's it's a loose bound
but but but but it is abound in it and
it does work in practice and we see that
for some reasonable things so we we have
some results on you know some some image
data sets and some benchmark data sets
we get false alarm rates using isolation
forests as our anomaly detector false
alarm rate somewhere in the you know 10
to 20 percent range for reasonable
sample sizes so so we're very happy with
this very pleased with it so to finish
then outlier detection you know I talked
about the different unsupervised and and
and mixed our benchmarking suggests that
this isolation forest algorithm is quite
nice and and and and surprisingly that
these percentile methods or quantile
methods are not doing so well I should
say in passing you know obviously these
things don't work at all well by
themselves for image data we've kind of
discussed this already any kind of
signal data or time series data and so I
think the next steps here are I'm very
interested intrigued by things like Gans
and autoencoders and other kind of
manifold learning and density estimation
techniques that are coming out of the
deep learning literature and so that's
the next thing I want to try is can you
know there's there's some very nice
papers at the last couple of nips --is
about this and because you know I think
that might give us much better anomaly
detectors them then we can get using
these simple iid feature based methods
then we talked about the Arpad theory
which I account for their behavior I
think reasonably well then we talked
about simple presenting the the most
important feature is a simple or ordered
feature explanation incorporating expert
feedback using this accuracy at the top
strategy and finally guarantees for open
category detection I apologize for
running long and thank my funders and
open it up for questions fundamental
assumption about the nominal
distribution of the anomaly distribution
well the assumption I wanted to call out
is is it safe in my application to
assume that the anomalies come from a
well-defined distribution and can you
sketch how to weaken such an assumption
to allow the fraudster also in the group
not that the analyst in the group but an
arms race between well so I don't know
how to do that in a legging a
theoretical framework it seems to me
that we end up in having to think about
it more like a game or a mini maxing
kind of adversarial learning setup
instead to get it and try to get some
guarantees that way so that would be
quite different from this and of course
there is some interesting work in
supervised learning the adversary
learning for supervised learning and of
course everybody in deep Nets right now
is trying to deal with adversarial
examples in deep learning and and
obviously some of the strategies that
are being explored like using gans and
trying to map queries onto and the
manifold onto the data manifold to strip
out the these adversarial attacks that
many are very closely related to these
same ideas of could we detect the
adversarial queries
being outliers that fall outside of our
data distribution so so some I think the
I think anomaly detection will again be
part of the answer but but this theory
for for for open category will not be
part of the answer there we need some
some other more adversarial approach and
then justification was that DARPA Adams
thing run as an arms race between red
and blue team or was it so there yeah so
there was a red team that was actually
you know based on people from cert you
know the computer security guys and they
have this whole white paper on different
kinds of insider threats and
organizations that they've collected
both from DoD and from industry you know
my favorite one is the what they called
the insider startup that a sub team
decides you know the company doesn't
appreciate us we're gonna take the
source tree with us and and go start a
go form a startup but there were other
things like I mean there were there were
things like you know someone who's
passed over for promotion survivor guilt
all these and so they have this whole
set of things a lot of them very
psychological and then they hired a
scriptwriter to kind of write scripts
about what kinds of emails and text
messages would these people be
exchanging in addition to their desktop
data then they acted out all of this
under this desktop and monitoring
software and then overlaid it on the
behavior of real employees in the
company and then we had to you know had
access to this in a very controlled
setting and we had to see if we could
find those red team inserts so but
unfortunately we don't really know how
hard they were yeah and and of course we
don't have access to the data anymore it
would have been interesting to once we
had the ground truth labels to go in and
see well so how are how should we train
a supervised learner you know like kind
of nearest neighbor classifier figure
this out quickly we don't know yeah in
the weather station example I'm curious
well most of the anomaly detection
algorithm you talked about seem to be
optimizing for for really low false
alarm rates and great high tensions but
in some of this
depending on how you're reacting to the
anomaly you might be able to tolerate
lots of false alarms but depending on
what's important and and how you're
recovering from a problem house
connectors in the weather station what
happens when you detect an anomaly well
so so in in all existing weather
networks that I'm aware of
they have a lot of flags and then they
rely on some human eyeballs to look at
them all so for instance Oklahoma
Mesonet is the best weather Network in
the United States they have a big budget
and they have four full-time
meteorologists for a hundred and thirty
stations so scaling that up to twenty
thousand stations in Africa I mean to
heck of a lot of I just don't think that
strategy scales to the Internet of
Things so that's why I think we need to
bring much more intelligence to bear
also most of the existing and weather
networks they use basically hand coded
expert systems for code for writing
these you know problem detection rules
and so they're completely ad-hoc and and
so I think if we keep you know it's I
think in some sense low-hanging fruit
for us because by bringing probabilistic
inference on top of the alarming we
should be able to greatly we'll still
have lots of alarms but we can say this
you know these 1,000 alarms are really
just due to one failure and create a
trouble ticket for it so we're we're
trying to build it we well we are well
on the way to building a system where
the there's sort of the the weather
network manager who every day logs in
and he gets a report of what are the new
failures we found since in the last 24
hours and then he can very easily create
trouble tickets and assign those to the
field engineers who then will be
scheduled to go out and do the repairs
and in our dreams that would be
integrated with an inventory system and
you know on and on but that's that's how
they're set up give a lot more knowledge
than usually about house and house
sensors failure engines and sensor error
models and right which riches must be
this NASA mission control here aware
where experts have very rich models
about how centricity or whatever just
units like this like doing weird things
to pay filter
right so I think yeah a real amateur
system all presumably ultimately we find
like these recurring anomalies and so
then they bring them in to the lab and
say okay what's going on here and then
like we we've already had this happen
wasn't due to art we didn't cover with
our code but there was a you know a
manufacturing defect or design defect in
the station and so all the generation 2
stations are having to be replaced with
but but but right over time you would
accumulate a library of failure models
and with very specialized detectors for
those but we want this anomaly
infrastructure as a fallback because
there's always something new you know we
haven't had any of our stations attacked
by an elephant yet but I'm sure it'll
happen right and Oklahoma they have
unbelievable stories about cows getting
into the thing and and you know it's
just we you know what what does what is
the symptom of a weather station where
some ants have decided to lay eggs all
over the circuit board you know it's
hard to have a disease model for that
that yeah you know I was just wondering
about the online case of anomaly
detection you seem to assume here in the
problem statement that the nominal
distribution is stable over time
absolutely yes the nominal distribution
starts drifting over time because system
identification changes right and so yeah
somehow we're going to have to track
that distribution and yeah we haven't
confronted that case here although in
the weatherdata case it's chick it's not
stationary but but but but it is very
predictable on an annual cycle on a
daily cycle there are lots of periodic
components that you can you know with
search traditional time series
techniques model and pull them out of
the signal and then you know in your
dream you have now uncorrelated white
noise and then it looks it may be it's a
part of the answer but if
I'm we actually weaved we've tried we've
we spent a whole year trying to do good
feature engineering and decided this
isn't working for us so because there's
it's just too much work to do all that
modeling and when you make the modeling
errors then edit reduces artifacts and
then then we start making mistakes
because of those so we're looking now at
basically looking at nearby weather
stations that should be experiencing the
same disturbances the same annual or
daily cycles and then looking at you
know comparing them how well can we
predict one using the other or what's
their Joint Distribution and using that
side do the anomaly detection stuff so
yeah that's I mean so it's between yeah
yes and we and actually we need to
retrain the models really sort of a
sliding window thing because again the
nature relations changes in and
wintertime for instance precipitation is
is a very it's our most important
variable our most probable problematic
sensor and and it has the smallest
spatial scale in terms of spatial
smoothness in the winter time right if
we think of without the Pacific
Northwest it's a very very smooth very
large storm right it affects the whole
Pacific Northwest and so if it's raining
one place it's good should be raining at
another station and we can use that
correlation but in summertime or in the
late spring when we get these showers
stations to come extremely uncorrelated
and and so then we need to have in a
sense switch models to use a model that
corresponds to a showery day with lots
of little cells and really I think we
need to be tracking that because it
really is happening day by day weather
like the first day of a rain event it
might have this large-scale and then by
the third day it's it's into these
little uncorrelated things and so so I
think we actually need to attract that
kind of larger spatial phenomenon and
speaking of larger spatial phenomenon
another thing is if you have a spatially
clustered set of anomaly of alarms all
ringing at once it's probably a real
weather event and an unusual weather
event not any of the stations broken
and that's you know now it's a it's not
anywhere in our system but but the
meteorologists definitely know this and
of course their other data sources like
satellites and radar and and things that
we can use to as additional sources of
data for this
[Applause]